okay good morning everyone
sorry for the delay
um so before we start I just quickly
want to address
an error I made
so um I had a member reach out to me to
ask to reschedule a bill trying to think
of the bill number off the top of my
head I thought of the wrong bill
so it was my error
so I rescheduled HB 1431
when I meant to reschedule HB 1278
so
HB 1431 will be heard end of day
February 8th as well as the time to be
determined on February 8th for HB 1278.
I want to assure everyone there was
nothing nefarious going on
it was simply an error
so with that said
I'm going to open the public hearing on
and
call up
representative Mary Jane Wallner
oh
I don't I don't see is is representative
McWilliams not here are you
um
oh so you're going to introduce the bill
for her
could you
I'm representative Mary Jane walner and
I'm from Concord you're right almost in
my ward so you're just straight away
from me so
um glad to introduce this bill today I
am a co-sponsor
and what it sets up is a commission to
take a look at the way
we deal with child care
a rep Appeals
this looks at setting up a commission
just to study it and I think it's a
great idea to take a look at something
new a new way of doing a new way of
doing appeals and I think this would
give us the opportunity
to take a look at what other states are
doing
take a look at we've been doing it this
way I think I was a child care provider
for about 50 years and I think we've
been doing it the same way for about 50
years so this would just give us the
opportunity to take a look at some new
ways and some different ways of dealing
with appeals for child care providers
ago because I remember representative
mcmilliams coming before us before with
a bunch of child care bills and we did
hear a lot about the appeals process and
the the violations that were going on
and and people felt there was
um
uh just some
I I can't I can't think of the word but
you know that it was really impeding the
business and causing
um problems for the child care centers
and to be even to to stay open and
um take children was this not something
that was studied during that do you know
uh representative McWilliams can
probably answer that better for you she
has introduced a number of child care
bills in the last couple of sessions and
some pieces of those bills have actually
passed and other pieces have not they've
been amended
um the interesting thing was I was
surprised when I looked to see that this
was coming to children and family
because the other bills have been going
to e-dna and you're correct that they
have done a lot of a lot of spent a lot
of time looking at child care licensing
and the issues around license licensing
issues
so I was surprised it was here so so was
I okay
right now thank you so much nice to see
you all with you nice to see you
so um
up next is
I apologize I cannot read this name is
it Marianne Baxter
[Music]
barter from the child care advisory
is the mic on
oh there we go there you go
um hi my name is Marianne barter I'm the
executive director at Merrimack Valley
daycare service and I'm the chair of the
New Hampshire Child Care advisory
Council and I'm in support of this bill
and I believe I can answer the question
that you had for representative walner
when Rebecca McWilliams put together the
bill and um different issues were being
studied this bill came out of that so
something that came up was an idea of
looking at the appeals process to make
it more fair Equitable for providers
and So currently the appeals process
that exists for New Hampshire is that if
you are given a violation from child
care licensing you would appeal back to
child care licensing and although we
don't question their integrity they're
wonderful people and we consider them
important allies in our work caring for
children it does create an atmosphere
where um
a provider could feel like there's no
point in appealing a decision because
they can't win
um whether that's true or not I don't
know and I have not studied the data but
it does create that situation so we feel
like this will improve the relationship
between providers and childhood and the
child care and Licensing Bureau
any questions
are there any questions
I would just like to say that that is
exactly the testimony we heard a few
years ago when when some of these bills
were in front of us from child care
providers so thank you for stating it so
eloquently thank you all right thanks so
much and then up next is Melissa Clement
from DHHS child care licensing unit is
here to answer questions did you want to
testify
can I ask you a couple of questions and
anybody else
good morning thank you I'm Melissa
Clement I'm the chief of the child care
licensing unit in the Department of
Health and Human Services and we're not
taking a position on the bill but we're
very happy to have this the issues
studied so we can find better ways of
doing our work we're always happy to do
that
so I guess one of my questions would be
do you find that the appeals process
could be impeding on child care
opportunities for parents right so if
these facilities
say
lose their license for a certain amount
of time or while trying to do the appeal
process
or how costly it is for child care
facilities and that that cost is then
passed on to families would that make it
more difficult for families in this
state to to get child care
so um let me walk you through we have
two different appeals process so there
is an administrative appeals process
which is what happens when an
enforcement action is taken on a license
which would be we've just chosen to find
a program based on the citations that
were found or maybe we've had to do a
conditional license or revoke their
license or suspended their license
that's a separate process that happens
through the administrative Appeals Unit
at DHHS this commission my understanding
is to study our what is called an
informal dispute resolution process and
that process is if a program is in
violation or we've we've found site
we've cited them for certain violations
and when they see the evidence that
we've presented on a statement of
findings and they feel that they are
actually in compliance with that rule
and they want to present their
information to show that we call that an
informal dispute resolution process so
that is the that is when they make a
request to the department for that
process and then we look at the
information and determine whether they
were in compliance at the time maybe we
didn't have all the information we
needed or that we made some errors maybe
in some of our evidence but the overall
violation might stand or that we've
removed
um the um the citation remains as is
because what they presented doesn't
change the citation
so that is the process I believe that is
meant to be studied under this
commission so it's it doesn't impact
their ability to operate um that would
only come through one of those
administrative actions which would be
heard through the administrative Appeals
Unit
not this informal dispute resolution
process so for the um informal dispute
resolution is that something that um
the owner has to be present for
um they can submit it either in writing
or we've done phone calls we've not now
with zoom everyone's gotten comfortable
with zoom we've done some meetings that
way for some historical purposes we've
generally do about 10 informal dispute
resolutions processes a year we have
approximately
740 licensed Child Care programs in the
state and we tend to do about 10 of
those informal disputes a year every
program gets a visit every year at least
one
and then my final question will be so
has
um
your department
and perhaps Proprietors of child care
facilities
try to
make changes without having to form a
commission I mean I know that there's
been a lot of complaints and I would
think that that would
um incentivize someone to
you know incentivize the department to
perhaps look into this without us having
to go this far you know to where
yourself and some Proprietors got
together and said hey this isn't working
let's see how we can do this has that
been something that the Department's
thought about so one of the things that
we're doing is we're looking at what our
adult adult license facilities do they
have separate processes they have
different processes that they do and we
have been looking at that we've also
reached out to other states to see what
their processes entails and how they do
it there so we have started looking at
it but honestly I mean we're not opposed
to this commission coming together so we
can get even more ideas from other areas
that we might not be thinking of perfect
are there any further questions
representative long thank you madam
chair uh thank you Miss Clement the um
the informal dispute resolutions
uh 700 programs how many
an average per year would there be a
finding of a violation
um so the
almost all programs honestly there's
findings we have what we call
critical rules which require a
corrective action plan and then we have
non-critical rules which we know as
something that needs to be corrected but
a corrective plan a corrective action
plan isn't required almost all programs
probably receive either a critical or a
non-critical rule because of the number
of rules that we have
so it's the the fact that I said that we
have 740 something programs and that we
have about 10 disputes a year
I would say the vast majority of those
programs have received either a critical
or non-critical finding
so follow up on me so the the critical
and non-critical at which point I I
remember the issue was uh that some of
these day care centers had to stop uh
until this was uh you know this was uh
adjudicated
um so I'm trying to think with respect
to critical and non-critical at what
point do you may suspend a license or so
if I mean suspension revocations are
even more rare than the informal dispute
resolution process we do I mean I think
last year we didn't do any the year
before I believe we had one that was
revoked prior to that we have you know
maybe two or three a year it's very rare
that we get to that point and that
process goes to the administrative
Appeals Unit so it is not part of the
informal dispute resolution process so
anytime any of programs license is in
Jeopardy or there's action taken on a
license that goes through the
administrative Appeals Unit not this
informal dispute resolution process this
is just for the findings at visits that
are requiring corrective action plans
okay thank you you're welcome
and so I have one more question now sure
so I mean would you agree that maybe
last year and the year before and not
the years to actually
oh yeah count how many times this has
happened I mean if we could get some
data from before that I think it would
be yeah yeah I believe I provided
previous testimony so I can certainly
bring that to this community as well
great all right thank you are there any
further questions
okay so I have no more pink cards so I'm
going to close the public hearing on HB
1364 and our next hearing will begin at
good morning again everyone I'm going to
open the public hearing on HB 1520 and
um call on representative Cody Lander
thank you madam chair members of the
committee excuse me one second
feels like it's right in front of my
face
thank you for hearing my testimony today
I greatly appreciate it for the record
my name is representative Cody bellanger
and I represent the center of the
you asked my constituents that and I
think we might have a brawl
this bill seeks to provide transparency
back into our our Guardian items
the story that I'm about to tell you
today you probably have heard before or
um I've talked to you about it
personally but many of you know that I
have adopted my nephew
and he is now my son
the process in which requires that we
needed a guardian ad litem
the guardian that litem was appointed
and I was not aware of such a cost which
was seventeen hundred dollars
um on numerous accounts I asked for a
bill
and she never responded
so I looked at the statute and I noticed
that she's not required to provide one
and I said well why the heck is this the
case so this is why this bill is before
this committee it is a simple tweak
so simple
it's not even a full half a page
all it does is seek to require the
guardian ad litem which shall provide an
itemized Bill to the paying party and
all parties shall have the right to
right to have the right to request the
itemized bill for review
that's it short sweet simple to the
point
for that I'd be happy to take any
questions
thank you thank you for your testimony
and thank you for this bill
I just wanted to ask you can you think
of any other service that you get that
does not give you an itemized bill
nope I don't think so thank you
are there any questions for
representative Belanger
okay well I have no more pink cards
that's the quickest hearing we've ever
had
okay good morning everyone I'm going to
open the public hearing on HB 1518 and
thank you madam chair members of the
committee again my name is
representative Cody bellanger and I
this bill was kind of a thought bubble
last session
um of last part of the first session
excuse me
um
when I brought forward my bill for
adoptions and one of the comments that
got brought up to me was is
there a home study done in the first
portion of guardianships and the answer
is no
um and again going back to my story my
wife and I adopted my nephew we filed
for Guardianship and we had him form
from excuse me
August of 2018
and he was
our we were his Guardians until August
of 2021. so to give you that time frame
um in that time window nobody came to
visit the house to make sure that he was
living in a safe environment now granted
we have a safe environment of course
um but the
no no individual no dcyf agent No Child
Care Agency came out to do a safety
check if you will so thought bubble was
born
there are some things that I need to
address with the child care agencies the
dcyf has reached out as you've seen in
the fiscal note the intention is not for
them to do it as as the fiscal note
clearly states they would need to add
additional staff
um it was kind of
wasn't really sure and I have reached
out to multiple child care agencies and
they think this is feasible the the
other problem that we're running into is
the the cost
um as currently the way that the bill is
written it states that the 125 dollars
would be paid for by the guardian to the
courts
um but what it what needs to be amended
and I apologize I don't have an
amendment today but I will be bringing
one forward
um
the the cost will go to the child care
agency but the judicial branch will
still be allowed to waive as they
currently do in the petition process
when you are petitioning to be a
guardian
um the other concern that was brought up
was the term adequate who who determines
that
currently the way the process is done in
an adoption case is that you have the
Child Care Agency come out they do a
determination to see if you have a safe
home and then it is
sent the report is then sent to the
court and then the court reads it and
then they decide it would essentially be
the same scenario if you will and that
will be the intention so what we want to
do is provide the same process the other
thing and I'm not entirely sure of as I
have not heard back from the child
agency agency's child care agencies
excuse me if 30 days is adequate enough
for them to get out there provided that
a guardianship has been placed there
will be an amendment brought forward
hopefully by the end of this week I
asked for the request but they did not
get it back to me in time
with that I'm happy to take any
questions I know it's a little confusing
and I apologize but you will have the
questions
um so what currently what is what is the
if if I might clarify Madam chair you
mean for an adoption
if that's what this bill refers to then
yes
um So currently there is no visitation
during the guardianship process so there
is no cost
but the cost of a home cost of the visit
shall be no more than 125 dollars paid
for by the guardian the court May issue
a waiver for this expense correct
currently there's no cost for that
correct because there's no process
that's currently being done okay
and then uh my next question is when you
refer to child care agencies what are
you referring to we're referring to
um as it states a Child Care Agency
approved and licensed by the Department
of Health and Human Services such as
Beckett family of services Waypoint
um
I'm sorry those are the only two ones
that I know off the top of my head okay
thank you
further question representative long
thank you madam chair uh thank you
representative the the
um so just to clarify on uh the first
page 22 the 125 dollars will be paid for
by the Child Care Agency is that what
you're looking to amend that by
uh thank you for the question uh
representative long and no so the
intention will be that the the Guardians
will still pay that but they will pay it
directly to the agency rather than the
way that it's currently written it says
paid to the judicial branch and um that
was not the intent of the bill Okay so
so the guardian the guardian will play
pay directly to the Child Care Agency
yes sir okay and the 125 dollars how was
that um it's just a placeholder
um I saw that yeah I mean I know
Waypoint is a thousand dollars their
home studies their home study is 1100
that's um that's a bit more of an
extensive process I mean you're going
through background checks and
um the intent of this is just to ensure
that the house is safe knives aren't out
um you know you got a pool that's
uncovered that the kid could fall
through
um because
um if I'm being completely transparent
when I first got a kid these were things
that I didn't even think of
um and it's just to make sure that the
house is safe
um and uh
yeah there's no book about being a
parent I mean there are but
it's not easy
uh one more follow-up follow-up so uh
and with respect to uh receive a home
visit are there different
kinds of home visits should this be
defined as to what your
looking for whether you know it's a high
end or a low end or
a I mean a home visit
it's not detailed as to what that would
be
so
thank you again for the question
um so one of the things that was
suggested was that we take a look at the
adoption statute and see what is said I
definitely don't agree that we need an
entire adoption statute essentially
applied but I do agree that the home
study should
kind of be outlined as to what the
expectations are
um and again that's going to be the the
cost analysis and what's that what that
cost is going to be for for Waypoint or
other services that would be doing this
okay and uh one more if I may sure uh
the um so
so if this bill were to pass if if a if
a grandparent received guardianship
this would require the grand Prime to
pay for a home study correct
correct but but again they'd be able to
file for that waiver
when they're filing for guardianship at
representative Blanchard
um as someone who has gone through the
adoption process three times
um
there's no that blows my mind that
there's nothing that you can just take a
kid and be like okay this is my kid and
no State services
have to come in
um
I mean we had to pay
we had to pay for everything with an
adoption but they came in
multiple times
in six months they came in six times in
six months
and we had the privilege of paying for
that each time they came in and they did
like they talked to my my other kids
they you know they looked all around my
house
um that's mind-boggling that there is no
um you know first 60-day you know 90
days even to that question oh I'm sorry
um the um so it's it's not set up like
the adoption process and that's what
you're looking for that it will start
looking it will start
to
um to kind of mimic the adoption process
is that what you're talking about
that it would mimic a home study but not
as
as not as big
thank you for the question yes I mean
essentially
um when we filed for guardianship uh we
saw nobody in again 18 to 2021 no one
came to visit except for that adoption
process which ended up taking place
between September and December of 2021
uh excuse me
um
2020 and I apologize
um so
um
yeah nobody is coming to visit these
homes during a guardianship process
there is no requirement
um to to do so so this is just seeking
to and again this was brought up last
during the first part of the session
when I brought forward an adoption Bill
many members of this committee were like
wait a minute the
we're trying to fix this adoption piece
and make it a little easier but there's
nothing being done on the front end and
I was like oh wow you're right I
completely forgot about that part let's
go ahead and fix that this session so so
that's exactly what this is trying to do
um Rome wasn't built in a day it's going
to take a little bit of a process to
kind of go through some of these bills
through some of these rsas and fix them
to kind of mimic but this is an
important piece I mean you can't
someone who is a gotten guardianship
twice and have adopted once
it blows my mind that there's no process
for someone to come and visit the home
and that's what this bill seeks to do
oh my gosh I totally drew a blanket
representative Grossman
I'm sorry thank you madam chair
um thank you for bringing this forward
representative Belanger
um
can you describe your amendment that
you're planning on just a little bit
more and will it include the definition
I would I if I may I would
um
really not want to discuss the amendment
until we have it in front of us you know
what I mean
um I I think if you want to ask the
question will it include the definition
of home study would be you know a good
question but I really I really feel it's
it's kind of jumping putting the horse
before the cart before the horse to
talking about an amendment that's not in
foreign
thank you I can I ask Will it include
the home study definition your planned
amendment that we don't have
yeah so um it wasn't going to but as to
representative Long's point it should
and and to yours as well um and thank
you for the question sorry I'm trying to
jump the gun here talk about putting the
cart before the horse
um and so
um when I get it back I will ask for
clarification and that'll be one of the
first things that I do this evening
instead of going and taking care of my
sleep
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
um uh representative Belanger in
um you have in the event that the home
is neither and the three words I'm
focusing on here are safe or adequate
and in RSA
436 under definitions neither safe nor
adequate are defined do you
um
would you be open to
putting the definitions in your
Amendment
thank you for the question
representative Schiller
um so to answer your question
no
but because not because we're we don't
want to uh it's more so the fact that in
the 469 it's not stated so we want it to
mimic the well as I'm a only sponsor on
this bill I want it to mimic the the
adoption statute and allow you know
adding in the either safe or adequate
really kind of leaves that up to
um
personal opinion
follow-up
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my second question
um with regards to the fiscal note
it's going to be a significant
amount of money
much more than 125 dollars would cover
because it looks like
the Department of Youth and Family
Services will be required to
do a home visit or sub out a home visit
write a report on that home visit submit
it to the court and then it says that
whoever performed the home visit is also
required to appear in court so
um based on how many
Foster placements because that's what
this is what this deals with
specifically right is the Foster
placements
guardianship placements my bad sorry
guardianship placements we do have a
number on how many guardianship
placements we've had
over the past couple of years to get
kind of an average
um
has there been have you had any more
information come to you since this was
printed
from those agencies to give us an idea
of what we would be needing to
supplement their budgets with to make
thank you for the question
representative um so as I stated earlier
um we're gonna
I do agree that it should be
currently the adoption process is that
in a child placing agent a Child Care
Agency such as Waypoint or Becca Family
Services does an adoption
um home study
um and the intention would be for them
to also do this piece of it I believe
the intention will be within 90 days and
and if I may preface that as well I
don't think in the adoption statute of
the home study process that there is a
cost limitation
so we can always remove this cost
analysis completely and it doesn't limit
the the agency and
hope
charge for a simple home study which is
going to be far less than what would be
and I just want to add to if I may Madam
chair
um when you file for Guardianship and
the reason why
um I the the adoption the the process
for a guardianship visit is going to be
different than the adoption visit is
when you file for guardianship you must
also give a um you must sign a document
for a background check and I do believe
it's been a while
um a child abuse and neglect document as
well so when you file the guardianship
paperwork that's already filled out and
that's the only
background check if you will and I'm
putting it in air quotes that's the
current process now so you wouldn't need
to add that to
this part of the the home study wouldn't
be necessary because it's already being
done
representative
questions
all right sing none thank you so much
thank you madam chair
okay and that was my
one and only pink cards so I'll be
closing the public hearing on HB 1518
oh that wasn't oh she scared me I'm like
we are now ready to open the public
hearing on HB 1303 and I will recognize
thank you madam chair
and committee members for the record I'm
Deborah D Simone I represent Rock 14
covering Atkinson and Plaistow two of
the most southern
um
HB
1303 is merely housekeeping
the current
um
the current RSA
458 if you go to
um
Roman numeral seven
it states
when either party is
an habitual drunkard and has been such
for two years together that language is
very archaic obviously
and in today's Times uh we have other
unfortunate issues so that's why this
bill changes it to state
when either party habitually abuses
alcohol or drugs
and has been doing so for two or more
years together that's all it is is it's
changing the verbiage to bring it up to
date
all right seeing none thank you so much
thank you
and I'm an absolute failure on
scheduling today oh wait wait there's a
question representative also sure yes
thank you I'm sorry I was calling up the
RSA
to compare I'm sorry I was a little slow
on that one um thank you very much for
taking my question
where you have changed where either
party habitually abuses alcohol or drugs
and has been doing so for two or more
years just together
synonymously go with consecutively and
yes and if someone has engaged in some
sort of a
um treatment program but then
subsequently fallen out of that program
and relapsed does it start to clock over
I'm like yes so it would be that's why
we specifically kept the words two years
together be simply because uh if you
look at rehab and
what happens with people who try rehab
many times
it takes a few efforts to get there so
if a person is is habitually abusing for
two years together and then they go to
rehab and they're in rehab for x amount
um they have not been habitually
offending or or in imbibing for whatever
time they were in rehab
so the clock is going to start over it's
it's unfair to do it in any other way as
far as I'm concerned
I'm I'm assuming
that I don't know where it falls in this
section that the the starting of that
clock so that there is an accurate like
it's been this long
um is done by the courts so something
would have to be submitted right saying
like yes I have engaged in this program
so on and so forth yes
and does that need to be stated or is it
just implied
I believe it would be implied it would
go to the judges
um
Authority okay thank you very much thank
you
hey are there any further questions
all right seeing none thank you so much
thank you and folks that's a wrap on HB
okay members
um we're gonna
give me one second and I'll get
representative yokella back here and
we're gonna go in exact three Bells
okay
we're going to do 15 20.
I'm going to open the exact session on
House Bill 1520 relative to the
procedures for guardian of items
representative Belanger do you have a
motion
I do Madam chair I make a motion OTP
seconded by representative D Simone
relative to procedures for guardian of
items
you want me to go get you one up there
hi hi
um
so my concern with this bill is that it
doesn't really seem to
um
I'm not sure that it's going to actually
help the person it seems to me could
just
rendered or Services
regarding you know guardianable item
decision making
process and so how specific they need to
be about
um you know what they're doing doesn't
I think that this
I think yeah I am not sure that this is
actually going to
result in them saying okay we need you
know I showed up at this place for 15
minutes and we're gonna charge you 200
for that
but I think that that is what the word
itemized
right refers to am I am I correct that's
that's how you get an itemized bill from
a from a gal is they have to put that in
there and and I mean
if if we pass this and then find out
it's being done like that then I think
we can go but I I don't think we need to
do that I think itemized
really
but we also didn't have any people any
gaals
um testify as to what a bill like this
would look like well that's their fault
they had every opportunity to come and
testify you know what I mean
um representative Belanger wants to say
something if if I may Madam chair
um so uh
this
um
this this isn't being done at all
um and that's what this seeks to do
um
you know obviously I'm privy to it and I
have personal
personal experience with it but
um
when when I send for my business when I
send a bill I send it itemized it shows
the flat rate it shows the gratuity that
a customer is paying if it's on the card
it shows the fuel surcharge which is
five percent and then it shows what the
total bill is at the end of the trip
that's an itemized bill and if I don't
send that and I just send the customer
um the the total charge I nine out of 10
times they just go what was I charged
for and they want a breakdown and that
brings fairness to
to this and I think it would also with
it saying itemized you could bring to
the judge's attention is this what they
consider itemized right I mean
I just I really think that itemize
speaks to itself and and is going to
representative D Simone thank you madam
chair I think that the fact that there's
not one
um uh
Guardian Ad Litem in this room and they
haven't sent any emails either speaks to
the fact that
um I agree so as far as I'm concerned
the concern is the constituent who has
to pay these bills and itemized
I don't think the language can get any
anything else
representative long thank you madam
chair so right now the guardian
enlightened says uh 1700.
right because that's the bill you get
somebody would get for God itemized
means
I traveled this far to here for gas I
visited these participants for an hour
for a half hour
or or just visited at least at least
it's broken down as to what the guardian
enlightened did has paying for that
I at least want to know that you put in
the effort that you you visited the
people that you ought to be visiting so
in my opinion this itemized bill
no doubt it's more than what they're
getting now
um
isn't is it
correct that really the the guardian at
Litem is there to serve the court to
gather information for the court and so
if they their report to the court was
not adequate then the it would be the
courts that would say hey you're not
really doing your job here
um and the person paying for it really
is not the person that is
um
really judging their their work product
if that
well I think this could offer up the the
questions to the judge hey this didn't
happen or or what is this but people
have a right to know what they're paying
for
I think that's basically what it is
you're getting a service and you have
the right to get an itemized bill that I
can't think of one instance that you
don't get an itemized bill from someone
for a service is rendered and why this
so that's where I'm at
okay
is there any further discussion
all right seeing none I'll ask the clerk
yes
representative yes
representative Nelson
yes
representative Litchfield
representative Smith
representative law yes
representative
representative Grossman yes
representative Ultra
yes
so
um HB 15 20 will go to the floor within
Aunt to pass recommendation unanimously
consent
seeing none
this will go on consent calendar
representative Belanger please have the
um the committee report to me before you
okay up next we'll do
um HB 1364.
second and representative decimon
seconds it
and I'll just say that I I spoke with
the sponsor
and
um she agrees that we're concerned that
the time frame of this is not actually
enough time and we don't want to
shortchange
this study which is uh really needed so
she agreed with me that we could uh
bring it back next year and I actually
seeing none I'll have the clerk call the
roll
yes
representative
representative cross
representative Litchfield
representative Smith yes representative
long yes representative alisaya
representative Grossman Cass
ie
Bachelor
the clerk representative Petrino is he
is
so 12 to nothing
all right 12-0 the
um bill the bill will be it will go to
the
house for a recommendation of itl is
anyone objecting to consent
okay this will go on the consent
calendar representative rice please have
your committee report to me before
we end today
all right and then up next is
um
House Bill 1303
representative D Simone do you have a
motion I do Madam chair I move OTP
so there's a seconded by representative
Belanger
representative yokella do you have
discussion yeah
[Music]
um
so we are not just changing
drunkard to alcohol use or abuses
alcohol we're also adding drugs and I
think that gets us more down this line
of like
um trying to
have fall to no fault and all of that
where I think we probably should just be
moving more towards no just no fault to
not trying to prove it
um in in a court of law so I'm not sure
that this is moving Us in the right
direction it
um if if if we were to say that this is
just a house cleaning bill then I think
that we should have removed the ore
drugs
part because then we wouldn't be
we need to include this because
drug abuse is
a serious issue and that's why it's
being added when we get to the no fault
I'm happy to co-sponsor or sponsor a
any further discussion
all right seeing none I'll have the
clerk call the roll
yes
no
representative
yes representative cross
representative Litchfield
representative Smith yes representative
long yes yes representative Alicea
representative Grossman yes
representative Levesque
representative what's here yes
representative altilla
yes
and Madam chair rice yes
do you have any objection to consent
calendar
okay so this will go on the consent
calendar and representative decimal will
have the committee report to me before
that
you know I will we leave today okay
okay everyone welcome back
okay and
um
I'm going to open the public hearing on
HB 1103 and I will recognize
thank you madam chair members of the
committee
I agreed to introduce this bill uh and
submit it this year although it was
submitted uh last year last term by uh
representative Reed uh kind of got lost
in the covid stuff I think
um but I have personal experience with
what we're dealing with here and I it's
very important to me that we we write a
situation that I see as as wrong
so with this bill is seeking to do is to
ensure that the division of assets
remains a process of being fair and
making both parties whole and not being
used as an act of Revenge or uh
basically uh malice
um I was unaware until I went through my
divorce three to four years ago that a
judge in the Family Court can just order
you to sell something that you own even
if it's been in your family for
Generations if they want to equalize
assets
in my specific instance I had a
truck that I owned she had a car that
she owned and then I had my motorcycle
and the judge ordered that in order to
equalize the value between the truck and
her car which was a known value we had
estimates done on the truck estimates
done on the car Blue Book values were
known so we had the known gap between
them was three thousand five hundred
dollars and he said you must sell the
motorcycle and then give the first three
thousand five hundred dollars to her and
I said your honor I have three thousand
five hundred dollars can't I just give
her three thousand five hundred dollars
we appealed his decision he denied the
appeal to his decision and said no you
must sell the motorcycle and give me
proof that you've sold the motorcycle
so I come to you today with this bill
that says that if you've got the money
to make it equal and you want to do that
instead of selling a personal item
the judge can't order you to dispose of
that personal item for me it was just a
motorcycle and it wasn't really even a
fantastic motorcycle it was just my
motorcycle it wasn't an expensive Harley
it was just a Honda but
um the value between the vehicles was
known we knew how much money I needed to
get and if I have that money and I can
just make it whole and make the the
division equal without having to sell it
I should be allowed to that could have
just as well been an armoire that had
been in my general my family's family
for generations and generations and it
could have been ordered to be sold
losing a family heirloom
and that's just not right that's not
what the whole process of of division of
assets is supposed to be and I think it
causes more animosity between the
couples in a situation that's already
rough so I would rather see uh that we
tell the judges you can't do that if
they've got the money and they want to
just equalize the value let them pay
and that's all I've got
are there any questions for
representative Belanger
so thank you for being here today and
bringing this bill I'm not familiar with
divorces and and I hope that I never am
but
um
correct me if I'm wrong but
so I have a five thousand dollar
asset and it needs to be split into two
is that correct
that's one instance where they split
them yep uh
and this is just seeking to kind of fix
value right like yeah if the value is
known and you're looking to divide it
then you should be allowed to use cash
to make that work not have to liquidate
the asset to make it work
thank you
any further questions representative
long
think of Madam chair uh thank you
representative so when when you when we
know
the value uh I'm thinking of when we
don't know the value with respect to
um it says fairly compensate the other
party
uh for their interest
now what if it's a uh a brochure a you
know a brooch or whatever that might
grandmother was my great great
grandmother's uh we don't know the value
thank you for the question there's
actually two values to that one that's
not addressed by the court which is your
sentimental value
correct then there's a monetary value
that can be appraised by any Jeweler and
the judge has arrived at his
determination that there's a value to it
and like in my case he had assigned a
value between the two vehicles after the
Blue Book values of the trucks and he
knew how much money had to be made up on
the case of The Broach uh if it is
appraised at a certain value and part of
the divorce proceedings is we had to go
through our assets and assign values to
them and then the other party could
dispute what the value was
or they could accept those values
and that's all part of the whole
Discovery process in the beginning
leading up to things when those get
divided
that's when the judge says well I
understand this is worth x amount of
money
and he can turn around and say
rather than you keep it and give her
money I'm going to make you sell it and
that shouldn't be allowed
thank you madam chair thanks for taking
my question so is it up to the is that
with the judge's discretion of whether
or not you can sell it or is it you have
to sell it
the judge makes the determination in my
instance his order was that I must sell
it and when we appealed the order he
denied it out of hand and said no you
must sell it
okay but it would be up to the judge
whether or not it is up to the judge
right now and what we're seeking to do
is sort of tie his hands just a little
bit and say if the money's available now
I have no problem with liquidating an
asset where the person can't come up
with the money such as a home you know
um
if you don't have the money to pay out
and equalize it with cash
selling it and then dividing the
proceeds is the way they usually go
that shouldn't be used in a situation
that's going to cause more Strife
between the parties okay thank you for
taking my question
representative alchiller
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative Spillane for taking my
question in the statute right now
I see that your
proposal is to add a section
for
yes
right
um
four it says the court shall specify
written reasons for the division of
property which it orders
so
um
it would did the court not specify the
reasons for
the reason given by the court was that
the difference in the two vehicles
primary Vehicles was three thousand five
hundred dollars and so they ordered the
sale of the motorcycle which was
considered a secondary vehicle with the
first 3500 I got from selling it to go
to her so in that instance their written
reason was just the values aren't equal
so you must sell it they did not give a
written reason as to why selling was
imperative or why he refused the appeal
to just give cash no written explanation
was given and
representative
thank you madam thank you madam chair
and thank you for taking my question I
appreciate it
um I'm not seeing anywhere in the RSA
that it says that
you cannot
uh create a bill of sale and purchase
there's a lot of ways of getting around
things I ended up selling my motorcycle
to a friend and a year later I bought it
back again
but why should I have to go through that
if I had three thousand five hundred
dollars right there
um and it ended up just causing a lot
more animosity during the divorce
process because now it was looking like
all right seeing none thank you so much
and up next is representative Ellen Reed
thank you madam chair and thank you
honorable members for welcoming me to
welcoming me to your committee
um this bill was originally my bill I
put it in last term 2020
the year it was out of this committee
ought to pass on consent oh headed over
to the senate in the Senate I believe
and was one of the casualties of the
mass tabling event
so uh this this uh as my testimony says
this was originally brought to me by a
resident of my County who went through a
divorce similar to what you just heard
from representative Spillane the judge
ordered the cell sale of a Sentimental
vehicle
the person offered to give the money
directly the cash directly and the judge
denied that
um so not knowing a lot about child and
family law I wanted to make sure that
before I put a bill in on behalf of this
person and I was doing my due diligence
and making sure I didn't mess anything
up so I contacted UNH law school and I
asked them is there any reason a divorce
judge should be allowed to force the
sale of something when the other party
has the cash to compensate the other
party not a single lawyer at UNH law
school could tell me that there would be
such a reason nor
did that would there be any reason not
to to have this in in statute the
domestic violence advocacy project and
NH legal assistance both reviewed this
bill this is the same exact language
that I used last term
and both organizations found no reason
to oppose this bill
so with that I felt safe enough to
proceed forward with the language
um and I'm I presume I'm you know kind
of preaching to the choir here when I
say that
divorce judges are instructed in law to
um to determine the Equitable division
of marital
marital property so that's what their
instructions are and if someone is able
to fairly compensate that cash amount
that the judge has ordered and yet the
judge says no you have to literally get
rid of your property that you have a
Sentimental attachment to that doesn't
benefit the other party at all it's just
punitive and in that case I feel that
the judges are overstepping their um
their directions in kind of punishing
someone just by making them give up
something that they are sentimentally
attached to
so I'm happy to answer questions I have
several references that I've included on
my because I did do my research last
time
okay seeing none thank you so much thank
you so much okay and that will conclude
the public hearing on House Bill 1103
yeah the only thing about executing is
we weren't going to exec so some people
may be looking online
I I get it that if we can exact and we
all agree let's get it off our table
however there's members that are
streaming in uh for whatever reason why
they couldn't get down here
um where they're not going to be on the
I mean if we if we could exec the bill
okay I'm going to open the exact session
on House Bill 1103 representative
is there a second
seconded by repulate Senator Belanger
all right seeing none I'll ask the clerk
yes
representative Smith yes representative
law yes representative
yes
representative I also welcome yes
representative that's me yes and Madam
chair rice yes
so the motion is adopted and unanimously
any objection to consent seeing none
this will be placed on the consent
calendar
okay everyone welcome back I'm going to
open the public hearing on House Bill
1118 and recognize representative
Barbara Griffin
thank you madam chair
thank you honorable members my name is
Barbara Griffin and I am a
representative from Goffstown I propose
and ask for your support for
hb118 this bill proposes to add a fact
to be considered by the court and in a
determination of parenting
responsibilities where a parent has died
or a guardian who has held the position
for two or more years has died and the
fact that I'm asking to be considered is
the contact that the child has had with
the surviving parent
and the wishes of the guardian in estate
planning documents again the period to
be considered after two years
I bring this legislation because of my
years of practice as an attorney in a
guardian ad litem and particularly in
the past two years the need to consider
this fact has become apparent
before I get into that I've been
practicing since 1987 have held a
license in Massachusetts for many years
currently hold a license in New
Hampshire I have a master's in social
work from Boston University I've
conducted a criminal and civil jury
trials I've appeared before The Supreme
Court but over the last decade plus I
have focused my practice on family law
matters in that role as attorney and
guardian ad litem I have seen the number
of termination cases rise
and they have risen specifically over
the past couple of years due to covet
children are being exposed to the issues
of covid outside of the issue of
exposure to covet and from a child's
perspective that is what had become a
very frequent topic of discussion of
death
and children like stability and I was
finding a lot of clients people bringing
forward petitions who when asked why are
you bringing this forward the response
was that the child in their care wanted
to know what would happen if anything
happened to the person they recognized
as their caretaker and that caretaker
realized that they had no ability to
have any say in what would occur should
they die
so children themselves may or may not be
subject to Parenting orders and when
they are they may have a contact only
with one parent not due to any court
orders but actual practice and I've run
into that in a number of cases and have
currently in a pad terminations where
the other parent has simply been absent
so the question in the determination in
those cases is clearly just one of best
interests and are the facts there to
allow the court to enter the termination
children can also be with guardians
sometimes they are family members
sometimes they are not and have little
or no contact with the parents who may
or may not still be in the area and
these Arrangements do go on and on for
years I have been in the home of
grandparents who have served of
Guardians maybe a child at substance
abuse issue they consistently vote Voice
the hope that the child will someday
become competent to parent and Conquer
their drug addiction
and I frankly in all of the cases I've
had any follow-up that has not happened
in the grandparents or other Guardians
have gone on to become the lifelong
guardians of that child so it does
happen for many reasons
and as I stated earlier with kovid
there's a generation of children who
have become directly confronted with the
possibility of death in either
themselves or their caretaker because it
was flat out part of the whole school
thing that went over was that everybody
was so sick and might die and you
couldn't go out so it did become a very
real fear for children who are often in
situations that aren't providing the
greatest stability to begin with
um so it really did have an impact
so whether or not that exposure to the
issue of death for due to covet was an
appropriate thing to be exposing
children is is really a question for
another day the reality is it happened
and they were asking their caretakers
what are gonna what's gonna happen if
you die
I had a Guardians say they were on a car
ride they were in the car I mean as a
parent you know I'm sure many of you
that some of the the darndest things get
said from the back seat of an automobile
right and that comes up so at that point
the reality that a biological parent who
may or may not be able to parent and who
may or may not have had any interests
becomes essentially the legal winner in
what may occur if there's a death in
what is the caretaking parent or a
guardian
um and again I come back to the fact
that I've I along with other Guardians
have had more terminations in the last
two to three years than we have during
our entire practice years and uh the
compelling reason has been that a
caretaking Arrangement has been in place
and the reality of the what a death
would do to it has become apparent
um now whether or not parents are
involved or not involved or the bill
goes forward or not whether it's good in
a particular circumstances not what this
bill seeks to do
what this bill tries to do is to allow
the court to consider what other options
might be appropriately available in the
consideration of entering parenting
orders
while the best parent best interest
standard may include a lot we know that
persons disagree on what it should
include and what weight it should be
given what I am asking you to do is to
ask the court to require to a
consideration of The Wishes of a
deceased garden guardian or the actual
contact a parent may have had
um the two years selected was not
entirely arbitrary I do a lot of dcyf
cases and in those cases of course the
presumption is that a parent has a year
in order to correct the conditions that
led to the finding of abuse or neglect
at which point the court is required by
federal law to issue permanent orders
the reality is those abuse and neglect
cases by virtue of the calendar pretty
much all go more than a year and I've
had cases where the year which starts at
the finding not the initial hearing has
gone on for almost another year by
virtue of trying to give that parent an
opportunity to assume this get the
skills that would allow them to become
apparent so in abuse and neglect the the
legal standard is a year two years is
really sort of where you get to see that
a parent is going to be able to go down
the path of Rehabilitation and assume
the care or not and in a guardian
situation as I said many of them start
off with the view that they will be
temporary right the child who's the
parent is going to be able to remedy the
situation or will come back right
they've moved away so we've assumed the
care of maybe someone who's not a family
member in order to continue that
relationship but when you get to be two
years you've established a new reality
for children in regards to their
stability and what should happen so
that's where the two years came from and
I just want to remind everybody that as
an attorney and any case is constrained
by the facts right I mean the facts are
what a court has to consider and the
clients in their lives are the facts
that go before the court
and the court is the one who has the
ability to consider the facts but
they're constrained by the law so as an
attorney I'm constrained is what I can
do with a client because the client has
brought me the facts and that's all I
have to work with and the court needs to
be given the opportunity to take those
facts and apply the law and I'm in an
effort to give the court the opportunity
to consider what has become in a
two-year situation than normal I've
proposed this bill to allow the court to
take into consideration either the the
intent of Guardians when they have done
estate planning documents or what the
actual contact has been with the parent
and I'm not saying that's going to
prohibit a parent from coming in but I
would like the court to have to consider
it it will give them the ability to do
it as compared to someone arguing it
should be Irrelevant in light of other
standards and with that I thank you for
your time and I'm happy to take
questions
are there any questions representative
Belanger
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative Griffin for being here
today and providing your testimony
presenting this bill
so
I'm going to preface this Madam chair so
before you ask me where my question I'm
going to get there I promise okay
um so I have adopted someone and I'm a
current guardian of another child if I
die
and my documents state
that they go that my guardianship rights
go to my wife even though my wife is not
currently the guardian for this second
child
and I have proven Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt
that my relative is not able to care for
the child in question
would this bill allow the parent to
um
be considered for my guardianship
I I guess I need to back up a little bit
Reasonable Doubt would not be the
standard use in these proceedings as to
an adopted child you are the legal
custodian so your estate wishes
um would control regardless and and your
wife or if that other person has not
adopted as an attorney when you walked
into my office that I'd say why not
um but that that would be sorry I just
want to the adoption was just to preface
I'm referring to the second case where
I'm at no no I know but I but you made a
certain assumption that we were going to
globally possibly globally treat them
the same and I'm simply pointing out
that you've already got a circumstance
where even the adopted child would not
be treated
um there would be some different
standards going on your estate planning
documents under current law would have
no legal effect on a guardian child it
might be considered
um but there's no requirement for it as
you're a guardianship terminates at your
death or the death of the child and
guardianships are always temporary you
can get a final guardianship order at a
final hearing but the guardianship order
itself is temporary and always subject
to modification
by the parent I will presume given the
circumstances of most guardianship cases
to reopen it as to either parenting time
or a termination the only difference is
the standard that is used in considering
whether a guardianship is is terminated
will be different depending on whether
the guardianship entered as a result of
an agreement of the parent by agreement
a lot of time parents agree
we can't do it we're going to let this
person be guardian or whether the the
parent contested the guardianship at the
time the guardianship entered finally
so I
under this bill if you had done a state
planning documents
it would be considered as to both
children if the adopted child did not
have another legal parent
and I'm presuming with adoption that
there was a termination that allowed the
adoption and I understand we're talking
generally there's no adoption unless the
termination has already occurred so that
parent is legally out of the picture
upon your your the adoptive parent dying
they're they're no longer in the picture
whether the adoptive parent is alive or
dead
and and the issue as to a guardianship
then it reverts back to the parents
under the current law
and this bill
um in no way prohibit stops a parent
from still trying to seek correct to get
the child back correct I I can tell you
I
um
in Guardian reports for terminations I
distinguish often in my reports that
there is a difference between what a
court in a termination proceeding might
do and what occurs in a parenting case
and
um
questions for representative Griffin
representative long
okay Madam chair uh
with respect to child support is that
any consideration even though they've
been paying child support but haven't
had any contact with the child or
visitation well we are told in the
practice area that child support and
parenting are not related
so just so you so you know that
um
the reality is just for the com if the
committee will indulge me child support
is a consideration and termination
so if you the termination
factual criteria that a court must find
must have been in place for six months
in order for a court to find that the
facts exist to consider a termination
and and then it considers whether it
might be in the child's best interest
so factually if a child has if a parent
has failed to support
pay child support for a child for six
years for six months that would be
grounds for termination however
technically child support is not a
factor to be considered in parenting
decisions what it does go to is to the
ability to provide for a child but the
payment of Child Support itself would
thank you
um and and this is
both of these are just
they shall consider correct it's not a
thing you must do you know you must
correct yeah they just shall consider
correct and my understanding is what the
problem is is it correct that uh there
may be another you know another uh
parent comes in correct uh that may have
issues and we wait two or three years to
see if they can get over that issue and
that's what this is addressing yes and I
will tell you A lot of times what
happens when there's a parent that
doesn't have contact sort of on the
other side so to speak
um and I'm not saying this to be
um to negatively accuse anybody of
anything what you find often is is that
the party that all of a sudden pays the
child support becomes involved is
actually the parent of the parent or the
grandparent
um who has had a grandchild that by
virtue of their child not being a parent
that they all of a sudden want to get it
get involved
and you often have parents admitting
that that's where the money came from or
that's how they got the ride or that
I mean this is obviously addressing a
very unique circumstance where the
parents have not
been parenting the legal parents have
not been parenting so we're so keep in
mind we're in a pretty
um fortunately narrow group of
circumstances but as the focus on Family
Matters is more heightened and as
termination matters
grow I think it's important to give the
court the ability to consider a number
of factors
pretty good
thank representative alt Schiller
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative Griffin
um
as a
as a matter of law could you please
clarify
um
why you have chosen the court Shell
versus the court may I believe shall is
a little more is more emphatic
uh because yes and one of the reasons I
did that was I wanted it specifically in
the order because the court would then
have to enunciate clearly that is in a
written order as to whether or not it
was considered it would make it clear to
parties and litigants that that would be
a fact that they might want to prepare
for in connection with any trial or
consideration of the order and it would
also allow if indeed there is a guardian
ad litem involved in the case to
consider it knowing that the judge had
was required to consider it in a final
questions
thank you very much thank you and that
will conclude the public hearing on
House Bill 1118
so official today I got my
all of ours just have our last name
foreign
all right
so I'm going to uh open the hearing on
1305.
and I'm gonna call uh representative
thank you representative and thank you
committee again I'm Deborah DeSimone I
um Atkinson and Plaistow
you don't get much more self than that
so I'm going to open this bill 1305
referencing
modifying the definition of temporary
alimony that a court May award in a
pending
the important word there is pending
the reason that we brought this forward
is because
in a pending divorce case
all of the marital assets are not always
uh
given to the court yet
or made apparent to the court so in some
cases a respondent may require
temporary alimony
to get him or her through
financially the divorce case
and in some cases that can be
financially detrimental to the person
who's paying that temporary
alimony
so what we're asking here is
the uh
unless those formula limits
a party seeking the temporary alimony
pleads and the court finds that
immediate irreparable economic harm
would result If the percentage of the
formula were applied
so it's early on in the divorce
proceeding and we don't want
to
accidentally create irreparable harm to
either party
and that's why this is being brought
forward
and I thank you
okay uh
thank you for taking my question
um
my cons my concern
and so I'm hoping you can address two
things is that in their possibly being a
temporary alimony
um
finding if that's the is that the proper
word or ruling
um
while Discovery is still being made is
that okay well Discovery is still being
made that then
um
it becomes a Baseline
that mayor that may be inappropriate
is that was that your question was that
taken into consideration
is that your question that's my first
question yes thank you yeah um and it
wouldn't become a baseline it would
become specifically temporary until the
order would come forward deciding
whether they would or would not be
alimony and if there is alimony what it
would be this is a temporary situation
um okay so my follow-up question is
there's often
um
parties who will
make
take actions to hide their assets
or
dissolve assets prior
during discovery
so how would this address
someone who may be hiding significant
assets
well this is not going to address
particularly that area however what this
is saying is that if you use the formula
and it creates a legitimate
legitimate
uh
economic irreparable harmful
situation then the current Formula would
be
um unfortunately you're right people do
um
liquidate and hide assets during divorce
proceedings and this is so early in the
divorce proceeding that it's hard to
tell whether they are or are not going
to do that so we hope that the court
would figure that out however there
could be a person in the divorce
proceeding that deserves and needs the
alimony
but we don't want to devastate the other
person
in in doing that we want both people to
have an equitable
situation
excuse me
follow-up
all right last last one so if when
when the court is finding that one party
will be
paying alimony
what would the
how would if that party is as the court
finds to be in a position to be paying
alimony
how what would the immediate irreparable
economic harm be
because it seemed the court is already
applying the formula that says they can
pay
so like where's the
so if it comes to the courts
recognition yeah that it's going to
cause irreparable harm the formula
limits would not be used the court would
yeah
no
you have arrived representative
so
so with
my understanding is the court now uh
sometimes they don't do a temporary
alimony they just
saw the higher earner moves out of the
house and I'm going to ask you to pay
the mortgage until we come to a
conclusion on this
um so is this
getting rid of that no no not at all
what this is saying is in in your
scenario representative
um
they they the one particular party moves
out of the house and has to pay the
mortgage but the party that's left
behind may have been and still is a
stay-at-home
non-working member of the couple
and that person would require
or petition the court to require
temporary alimony
and that's when the court would consider
the temporary alimony later on in the
court proceedings when they divide the
marital assets thus and so that alimony
may be part of the Court ruling and it
may go away
but it's not going to change anything
else
okay so follow up for me thank you so uh
the temporary what you're saying may not
be temporary well it will be temporary
however
long that temporary portion will be
eventually the temporary will go away
then it will be up to the court to
decide whether this person gets alimony
so so I'm wondering if I mean
if I'm a judge I'm seeing that a person
is
able to pay temporary alimony and
plus pay for a lawyer to go through the
divorce that after the divorce this
guy's got a little more money on
you know you know he's not going to be
paying a lawyer anymore
so I I thought representative may have
asked something contained into that
my concern would be
temporary alimony be in the
um the basis the measure basis for
permanent Alma well it may very well be
if the person doesn't have the
opportunity to rehabilitate him or
herself and be able to become gainfully
employed
this person for whatever reason may
fall under the parameters of becoming an
alimony recipient
at the end of the divorce
again the temporary portion would have
no bearing on the ultimate outcome
it could be that this person needs
rehabilitative alimony which is another
statute
it could be that this person needs
lifelong alimony
that would be up to the court to
determine that
any other questions
[Music]
I have some
um
in in the statute right now it says that
there is a maximum duration of alimony
shall be 50 of the length of the
marriage unless the parties agreed
otherwise or the court finds that are
Justice requires an adjustment
to that
um
and in your bill you cross out the
online five you're Crossing out that
this temporary alimony shall not be
counted towards the uh essentially the
five years of or fifty percent of the
time of the regular alimony however
this temporary alimony may be
a different amount than would be
required on the norm under normal
alimony so if this temporary alimony was
for let's say a year and it was
50 percent less than the final Judgment
of alimony than the person that got
the alimony
uh judgment would be essentially have
this temporary alimony would have
counted toward their 50 of the time in
their marriage so they would have lost
that 50 percent of the
um what their alimony would have been
and so
for what reason
were you
wanting to change
um
this from not being counted towards that
because we want the temporary alimony to
be
temporary and not counted toward any
it's just temporary until the judge can
make its the court can make its
determination as to whether this person
should get alimony or should not
and this is really more about
the um
not creating irreparable economic harm
thank you for your clarification but the
the language that I'm specifically
referring to is such alimony shall not
be counted toward or subject to the
duration limits of RSA 458 19a Roman 3
but you're changing it to it
shall not be subject to the duration
limit so in fact you're actually saying
that that it's not going to be it can be
counted towards it and it the duration
limit can even be longer than the
current one well it depends upon how
long
are the reasoning there we know that
going to court for your divorce is
taking longer and longer and it could
so is it my understanding that you would
want the all of that 10 years to of
temporary alimony to be going against
their
um 50 percent of the length of the
marriage so if they were married for 20
years
then after the 10 years and they finally
get divorced they would actually be done
unless the party would be economically
egreged
thank you for that you're welcome
answer
uh okay I will adjourn the hearing on HB
1305.
you're gonna close it I close the
hearing adjourn
so
I received a
um that
she is detained in a meeting
and she has asked me
to
convey to you that
um we are going to be rescheduling as
she said in the beginning of today's
hearings House Bill 1278 relative to the
modification or termination of term
alimony to a date certain of February
8th
um
also uh House Bill 1431 is canceled and
will be heard on February 8th
and with those two announcements that
means that our business is concluded for
today
so
I will close
the hearings of uh January 25th and wish
so please stay in your seats for
oh the the Republicans can stay in their
no
we're done for the day thank you very
very much
yes